I don't think the United States should
go off intervening anywhere and
everywhere but I supported the
intervention in Iraq for several reasons
not just weapons but but Saddam's human
rights record we went to war and the
Clinton administration twice with Serbia
over both Bosnia and Kosovo over human
rights and the loss of it killed maybe
10% of the people that Saddam has been
responsible for the death so if you
count the war as he started and I think
you should so I thought that and his
ties to various terror groups not just
how kind of but a lot of them all
justified removing him from power I wish
the administration had gone in with
larger forces I agree with John McCain
on this or if not gone in with larger at
least made a quick correction once the
war started and I wish they fought it
the way Abrams fought Vietnam which was
what sometimes call clear and hold that
is to take an area and protect it and
integrate your own forces with those of
a local militia and protect everybody
and then move on and continue to do the
same thing rather than the Westmoreland
search-and-destroy of blowing through
someplace and shooting a lot of people
and then having the bad guys come back
and kill any of the good guys who are
helping you so I think that they have
only finally reached an Abrams strategy
in the late fall of oh six with the
appointment of General Petraeus so I
wish a lot of those changes have been
made sooner but I thought the
justification for removing Saddam was
was adequate I just wish it Ward that
fought differently